bitcoin stands to lift millions of
people out of poverty and that may sound
like a crazy idea but let me explain
since 1971 when the u.s dollar went off
of the gold standard we've had fiat
currencies so about 50 years now and
during that time productivity and output
has increased but the pay of the average
citizen has continued to go sideways now
what rich people understand is not to
save in this fiat currency this currency
continues to be devalued and debased by
governments and central banks around the
world rich people instead continue to
hold investable assets everything from
stocks to real estate to other types of
commodities and the reason why they do
that is because as that fiat currency is
devalued and debased those investment
assets go up in price the rich get
richer and the poor get poor quite
literally what we've watched for 50
years is if you simply tried to save
your way to financial security it was
impossible those that were saving ended
up losing and they continue to go
further and further into a dire
financial situation this is that feeling
that they can't possibly get ahead no
matter what they do there's no path to
financial security but here comes
bitcoin bitcoin is a decentralized
digital currency it's got a programmatic
monetary policy there's a finite supply
the reason why that's important is
because bitcoin is 180 degrees different
than the fiat currency the fiat
currencies have unlimited supply and
they continue to be debased
systematically bitcoin has that finite
supply there will only ever be 21
million of them and as more and more
people continue to opt to convert some
of their fiat currency into bitcoin
bitcoin's purchasing power rises bitcoin
has been growing at about 170 compounded
annually for over a decade and
everything around you gets cheaper and
cheaper when you hold bitcoin and so
ultimately bitcoin is the extreme end of
the best savings technology in the world
all of those people the bottom 45
percent of americans with no investable
assets and the millions of people around
the world that continue to get debased
or devalued away now they can simply
save in bitcoin that savings technology
can protect their purchasing power it
can prevent the erosion of their wealth
and bitcoin quite literally will lift
millions of people out of poverty as it
continues on a road to global adoption